i just saw something that was so funny
to me i don't know if you guys think
it's funny ah sometimes you see
something on [ __ ] uh uh in the inner
internet that makes sense well you got
this brian come on got that yeah how
many sentences are you selling i want to
see what you guys sound like biting
right now
[Laughter]
this guy's kind of a genius he's young
and i think he could be a really good
comic just based off of this and i [ __ ]
you guys if you don't think so watch
this
all right this is funny it's gonna be
terrible no i don't think it's gonna be
have an open mind give them a chance
i just think that some people you can
see them do one thing and you go oh you
could you could do you could be really
funny and stand up
if he's not doing it i love him
and don't diss him because he's young
and i i don't think he could be really
yeah you're the one that's the funniest
thing unfortunately the funniest thing
that cracked me up on the internet is
the kevin hart and don cheadle thing
that's why where he goes i'm 56 yeah he
goes he goes me i'm 57 6 or 57 kevin
hart goes damn
and he goes then don jill's law
no i didn't mean it like that you but
you didn't sail it but you didn't say
like that
he's just such a great actor but but
like they were having fun with each
other but such a nice person too don't
you oh you met him i've not met him i've
just said i'm desperate like i just said
hi yeah [ __ ] a nice person
this is on tick tock yeah this is the
video you're too old for tick tock b no
it was just it was somebody sent it to
me and i thought it was funny as [ __ ]
i think it's mda
oh okay oh thank you that's not that kid
dropping the balloon i know i was like
what do you think it was that kid
dropped in the balloon
do you know which video bro yeah it's
the one with the moose oh i love this
guy oh hold on you know this guy yeah
he's [ __ ] hilarious
is that he's he's oh so he doesn't i
gotta follow him yeah he does it all
like all the animals do you have a
tick-tock brain no
that one video has 16 million views oh
he's [ __ ] oh okay so he's no wonder
i'm not the only one who thinks he's
[ __ ] like i found this guy diamond in
the rough here everybody so talented
wait he's just like i was laughing it
was like it's hard to do this there's a
moose there it is the moose go
this picture pretty much started my tick
tock career because the first animal
video ever made was dedicated to just
how ridiculous this actually is and what
was true a year ago is still true today
at hundred pounds and seven feet at the
shoulder the moose is always going to be
one of those things god forgot to put a
scale limit on the average male moose is
10 feet tall about the same height as
the basketball rim you probably can't
touch somehow this roid deer is actually
closer to size to an elephant than an
actual deer also moose can swim and
they'll dive up to 20 feet in lakes just
to eat underwater plants which means at
least once in the history of mankind
some guy actually lived this and
probably never slept well ever again his
therapist drives a bentley also moose
can run through six feet of snow at 30
miles per hour those numbers might not
mean much to you but i bet this video
will it's not even the running that
scares me it's what the hell she could
possibly be running from and i don't
even know how to describe this either
the water's shallow or that's moose
christ it's the musaya you know that
thing where they say you should never
swerve to avoid hitting an animal 95 of
the time that's cause that five percent
is when this antler grim reaper's on the
road on a scale of one your buck makes
with weinstein if you hit one since its
entire body can come down to your
windshield and crush you the moves might
walk away but you're not coming out of
that without wings and a halo this right
here is why canadians are polite
landlords are moose and they pay taxes
to geese you'd be humble too we need to
have a serious talk moose
problem
[Music]
no it's interesting for sure
it's got 21 million views
[Laughter]
go to youtube
[Laughter]
watch this putting me you know i'm 56
years old damn
i'm sorry
i can sit up here and honestly say buddy
that was from a place of love got it
like damn you didn't if we could play it
back right now
these are two different dams
they're all [ __ ] real
so much i love kevin so much oh he's so
funny oh [ __ ] but yeah that's just
nothing you
the rest of you doing talk shows ellen
all you cool i'm gonna do one better
he's so good yeah it's like one where
he's like
he doesn't miss yeah everything he does
he does nothing bad nothing he's so
funny
that's gonna really
[Music]
because i'm i'm checking up on them
right so so you know with the whole car
wreck like brian is like it's it's been
so heavy and like
the response that we've got
is
i mean if if you want to make me cry
that will do it like the if you go to
the the poor ladies go fund me who
passed away here and start it all the
comments are firing the kid fans go and
find the kid yes
put pittsburgh it's like all firing the
kid fans like yeah t-fat army uk salsa
and t-fat k t-fat k-army t-fat k uh
t-back k army out of everything
dallas [ __ ] amazing uh it's all fine
and kid fans so they're at forty seven
thousand guys are so amazing and their
goals
and now we're getting so many like great
emails from cops and firefighters oh
yeah
and jason and i do you know i don't read
a lot of social medias but i do read the
emails
do me a favor quit sending me your
horror story that you experience because
it's triggering it ruins my day i love
the emails but when you describe your
horror story compared to i don't it it's
i think they're trying i think they're
dealing with their own pts
that's what they say they said i dealt
with this this is how i get over it and
that helps but the horror stories are so
[ __ ] horrific yeah i can't get
through them anymore so with all the
cops and the fine kid fans who you know
donated all this money i can't thank you
guys enough that made me feel there's a
there's a firefighter who also he was a
state uh trooper now um and he simone
guy from salt lake city and he he sent
me a video saying hey dude you know
brennan has ptsd and he's gonna have it
it's what we live with all the time and
talk to him make sure that's why i kept
calling you like i was calling almost
right yeah but i kept calling me text me
all the serious stuff so you know how do
you meet me so me and brian joke around
and he like sent me this long like
heartfelt text message
now remember i'm not making light of
this situation at all
this is me texting brian
yeah so he sends me this whole heart
like ptsd you got to talk to somebody
i'm here blah blah yeah this is what i
swear i know how he is and he keeps
calling i don't want to answer them
around my kids i don't want to answer it
right so this one is fun and he and i
are the same because i know what what's
going on in his head is look there's
nothing i can do to help like we can
talk but at the end of the day i didn't
talk about anything like that's not how
we process [ __ ] yes but also
like i also know it helps to talk right
right
if you can't if you can't talk to
anybody it's it's me that's you guys
don't should let your wiener
hang just a little thick size saves
lives so by the way we're talking we're
like it's all serious you're gonna be
okay this is your thing and this is what
this is a mission to i try to help these
kids
yeah i go that's i go brian goes you're
the hero and then what's right
i go i told you i said you're the hero
this is your role brother okay this is
your role you know be the prince and
then i just get this he goes i know i
know hey real quick between us dot dot
dot i'm a
super hero
and then he goes no i'm reading him he
goes for real i might be batman
which makes you
rob it
you gay
i knew it
and he sends a picture of the bad signal
he goes
seriously if you need to get a hold of
me i only respond to this okay which is
that bad signal
and i go no please he goes he goes then
i just get this
call me batman in private please
i was like i can't
so that's what
get that
because i was laughing so [ __ ] hard
i saw that [ __ ] artwork someone made
of y'all's batman and robin yeah
i gotta
rob and i knew it look at this one and i
kept getting the text and i just kept
watching it unfold holy giant dongs
batman
batman and yeah look at this game hey
look at his hand
that's genius whoever did this i love
you who did that tom john vaughan spy
man
and robin bye man and robin that's
[ __ ] tom john vaughan you're awesome
i'm batman you're the ass on ryan yeah
yeah
i'm i am batman and you're 50
okay